she's back let's see if we can get her
on do you have a do you have a mic
yes I do beautiful
I was a little shy I actually listened
to your show I'm not here to disagree at
all because I do agree with you
um with a lot of points but what I meant
to say is
um when I said Alpha I meant by the
female's profession because let me give
you an example Rick I went to a speed
dating event and there was one gentleman
I really liked
um he started to ask me about what do I
do and so on so um I'm currently uh
applying for the medical residency
well his face changed I tried to be very
agreeable very nice
I saw he was very interested and he
looked my way and looked my way all
night so when I came home I I did the
match he never matched me
um and so I this isn't the first time
it's happened and I noticed that I tend
to attract more beta than Alpha uh and I
don't understand because I just become
opposites that's because Opposites
attract
what do you think we're living here in
the medical field
yes physician okay and how old are you
34. okay so you make decent money and
where do you live big in a big city I'm
uh assuming
and no Suburban
can you tell me where or region I know
you want to be like
Pennsylvania Pennsylvania okay
I I I I I I I have gotten you know
compliments that I'm feminine and all of
these things I mean you sound feminine
on the air you know with the vocal tone
you know tonality you're very soft you
know you're definitely feminine sounding
but you're rubbing the guys the wrong
way if they're not like
the thing about women that that women
fail to understand in today's modern
world a lot of women that you know watch
my stuff is men don't view women like we
don't care about your degrees we don't
care about what you do for for a living
men look at women as Beauty objects and
that pisses women off still they don't
want to be viewed as a sex object or
does not upset me it doesn't upset me I
understand are you a feminine woman
though I don't know I I I do consider my
I I do consider that yes I I can't have
both traits but I can give way if that's
what he likes then sure you know I I
went out with a guy for a couple of
weeks he said I really likes the white
dress so I went to the store to buy more
feminine things and then he goes to me
for three days and I don't like that
type of stuff ah you don't like being
ghosted for three days why
well I'm a consistent person I'm
reliable I've been told that it's very
easy to communicate with me and I expect
the same but that's a demanding trait
like I expect you to when I when I do
this and you get back to me within this
certain time time frame right but
you're not in a position to do that
right
but if you like a woman listen if I like
a man I I text every day I I don't
bombard but I understand that but I mean
you're saying you want a strong virtuous
alpha male and the last thing a strong
virtuous alpha male wants is some chick
telling him if you don't get back to me
within a reasonable period of time then
insert whatever right like I'm not
interested or I have expectations it's
like guys that are on a purpose guys
that are strong virtuous alpha males are
going to text you or message you when
they want it and at the end of the day
if they don't message you it's because
they're not interested it's because they
have a better option something else came
up maybe another girl is more
interesting you know to them how how
tall are you
I am five foot five I am 128. okay
pounds I consider you know I I consider
myself of course I'm not a supermodel
you know I'm realistic um I don't know
uh maybe one day I'll go in the camp but
I'm too shy okay well look you know the
entire world's watching right now like
they want to know what you look like the
light you know the chat's going to be
like well what does she look like sort
of thing but I get that you want the
privacy but
I'm already hearing like things that I
don't like as a guy
when it when it comes to
these Dynamics because when you're using
terms like alpha female it's almost
always connected to a woman that's bossy
disagreeable
arrogant demanding
um like if a guy likes you trust me if a
guy likes you he will contact you
if a guy does your Vibe maybe not every
day
maybe every other day maybe every every
third day but it but if he's contacting
you if he's inviting you to go out
inviting you to do things uh showing you
off to his friends events you know he's
using you as arm candy he obviously
likes if he's you know if he wants to be
intimate with you if he makes advances
on you right making you know setting
like guidelines like if I don't get a
text back within two or three days and
that doesn't meet my expectations and
that's not good enough sort of thing
so what right like he he's he he's not
going to operate on your agenda you have
to remember these these these alpha
males they're doing [ __ ] with their life
they're not going to have somebody like
tell them you know like you have to
count out to their schedule or their
whatever and that's something that women
have a hard time
getting through their heads and
understanding is that you can't boss
these guys around you have to let them
be and you have to want to complement
you know their lives if you know what
I'm saying
right and and that's going to be tough
because look I mean
my doctor's a female
and she stresses me the [ __ ] out sitting
down with her for like 20 minutes
because she's always ripping through
stuff and she's
I saw her at the grocery store one time
with her husband and I felt sorry for
the guy like like these professional
women they're not attractive to me
whatsoever
and a lot of guys feel the same way I
got a lot of guys in my community
there's hundreds of guys a lot of them
are are top shelf men better looking
than me with more money than me and they
all say say virtue of the same thing
they don't want to be dragged around or
bossed around by they don't care about
your doctor they don't care about your
degree it doesn't matter how many of
them you have frame them the nicest
mahogany in the world it doesn't matter
them is she kind is she nice is she
beautiful is she sexy is she good in the
bedroom does she cook you know like does
she compliment my life that's what guys
are looking for
foreign
well you know I I I I understand what
you're saying I'm not disagreeing with
it but I you know I I like a certain
Alpha I feel like the betas just kind of
like our moths amazing well the problem
is is that a lot of women have their
expectations their expectations
tarnished because there's more beta
males out there about 80 to 90 of the
population will text you every day good
morning beautiful good night sexy I
can't wait to see you they'll just blow
up your phone with all their dumb [ __ ]
right but it's because they have nothing
better going on and that's why you're
not attracted to them so you're saying
that most of the guys you're dealing
with are beta males but when the nice
looking virtuous alpha male that you
want to be with takes three days to get
back to you then that pisses you off
because it it crosses some boundary that
you set there right you got it like guys
like this you have to enter their frame
you have to be willing to enter their
frame
well and I understand but it you know he
was telling me she likes to be
chivalrous he likes to be old school he
was contacting me every day and then he
kind of stopped so I I don't understand
if I put it I put I was honest I put in
the effort I expressed my feelings so I
I don't I'm not bothering us
41
okay and
did he have kids was he divorced was he
looking for family like what's his deal
never married no children
um I you know I never got to fully know
all of his deal I believe maybe I
presume that there might have been
somebody on the side
I guarantee there was how many times do
you guys go out on dates
about five times uh look there's like
there's no single women either
sweetheart right like women are talking
to a lot of guys
too well listen you guys know that
um when I like somebody I cut it out so
I just I
I understand you're
so mean like a 40 year old a 41 year old
you know successful guy can can date
down to early 20s up to his age if he
wants right
and if he's and if he's got great things
going on in his world and he's
successful and he has options
like you're kind of a hard sell versus a
younger hotter model if you know what
I'm saying
well I'm gonna say this rich I later on
I found out uh that he was with a woman
and
she was
a lot heavier than me
maybe he likes fat chicks
so I don't really a lot heavier than me
and I I don't know what you did for a
living but I I'm certain she was not a
physician
I know but you're but you're still
putting Merit on the whole physician
thing guys don't care about that
the only the only guys that care about
your job and your level of income and
your level of success and your degrees
are the dorks the beta males that you
don't want because these guys think well
I'm an engineer
she's a physician if we get married we
can combine our lives and you know we
can now buy a 4 000 square foot house
and have two cars
and we'll share everything right but
that's not usually how it ends up going
down you know for you you just don't
have interest in guys like that
it should look look you're at a like
the women in your sphere of life and I
don't know what you look like and that's
a big part of it right so this is
difficult for me to
deal with but the 36 year old
professional Alpha females looking for
the alpha male always have a hard time
understanding that they have to enter
his frame compliment his life and uh and
and get through their heads that they
are a beauty object to the guy
they're they're not looking at you as
let's be equals let's do stuff like that
and you know as far as the dude that
sorry and as far as the girl that he uh
chose over you the heavier one
what else is there to the story I mean
if a guy picks a heavier girl over a
thinner fitter girl
if that's me and I mean like you guys in
the comments tell me right now
there's something wrong with you
because I would never pick a heavier
girl over an attractive Fit Girl
most guys wouldn't
I I you know I I don't know I
I don't have an issue getting dates I'm
not trying to be defensive I I think
I don't know I I think there was some
insecurity on his part
let's do this you think let's do this
um the guys in the chat are finding this
a little bit tedious at this point the
thing that's missing here is a face to
face
I do private consults the links are
always pinned to the top comment you
shouldn't have a problem because you do
well in life because you're a doctor why
don't you book me for a private console
we'll have a conversation I'll help you
out okay
all right I'll think about that thanks
all right bye-bye she won't do it hey
guys I really hope that you enjoyed that
short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unpluggedalpha.com forward slash shop
when you click through you'll be able to
land over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational Essentials for health
immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out